hey guys Pete here it's time for the
weekly spoiler report so if you don't
like spoilers you should stop watching
right now but I do have a book giveaway
going on so check out one of my
non-spoiler videos from this week to
learn more about that everyone else
stick around to the end to see how you
can enter and with that let's get
started
so this isn't a spoiler in any way but
it is some sad news that the Peter
Vaughn the actor who played maester
aemon died this week at age 93 Vaughn
did a terrific job playing maester aemon
who is if you think about it or should I
say was since the character died a
secret Targaryen before that was even a
thing the character he played maester
aemon died of natural causes which is a
rare thing in Game of Thrones and it was
a powerful scene like most of the scenes
that Maester Aemon was involved in it's
really sad to see him go and he will be
missed
last week we talked about what looks
like a dragon fire attack that was
caught on film and leaked out for all to
see there has been a cleaner version
that was put out since then but we don't
learn much more it's just a little
easier to look at from what we know this
scene is a part of the collection of
scenes that they're shooting which
include the ambush but we're not sure
exactly where it falls in the timeline
or what else is going on the first guess
was that it could be Dragon Fire someone
getting burnt by the dragon but there's
some stuff that doesn't quite add up and
it could be anything so we're just going
to have to wait and see on that at the
same time we talked about the wolf
quarry scene that was going on in
Northern Ireland and Watchers on the
wall did secure photo that's not great
quality but does clearly show Kit
Harington being a part of the filming
there so we'll talk a little bit more
about this later but you know this is
all part of giant scene in the north
which which is shaping up to have a lot
of different characters involved lo
siete Raynaud's also pointed out that
there are women extras that were going
to be used when they start shooting in
cáceres and this is interesting because
there haven't been any scenes where
we've had women extras they've all been
battle scenes so far for the most
our again there's more news about this
later so I won't get too deeply into it
but it just all adds up to it being you
know the small folk and probably being
King's Landing
earlier this week I put out a short
boilers video because I was so geeked up
about these photos that came out of the
ambush scene but on that same day we
actually had some other news too we
found out that Peter Dinklage is back in
Spain that he's in cáceres which could
mean quite a few things it could mean
that he's there for the ambush scenes
that are being shot nearby or he's there
in advance for the king's landing scenes
either way Tyrians there which isn't a
big surprise but it's still good to know
and el periódico ex to the Medora
reported that they had pictures of
preparations for those scenes in the
city streets and it looks like things
are getting set up and in the following
few days they have even more stuff
that's really cool but if you haven't
seen the pictures that came out of the
highly anticipated ambush scene you
might want to go back and watch that
video that I made because when I first
saw the gallery that Hawaii put out I
just sat there and kept flipping back
and forth between them it's it's pretty
pretty cool-looking scene and set they
have going on there now if those photos
didn't get your juices flowing how about
a dead dog laying on top of a dead
Lannister soldier who both have arrows
through them on the battlefield this
next set that came from los siete Rey
nose is high quality in looks to be
taken right next to the carnage and is I
mean looks like the photographer's
standing in the middle of the shoot that
is pretty awesome again none of this is
really surprised we've known that this
is going on we knew that Danny's forces
were going to be attacking the Lannister
army as they're bringing their loot from
Highgarden but it just again like I
can't help but be a fan of this look at
this it's just great when I was putting
together today's script I had to laugh
because I was reading the story about
these photos on Watchers on the wall and
one of the sentences was just perfect
sooo the fury who writes the main
content for the site watchers wrote this
is
going to be brutal and I'm really
looking forward to it and I just thought
about how funny of a sentence that is
because brutality is not usually
something you're looking forward to but
it can be written so casually here
because it's just a part of this show
that we love so much so kudos to
Watchers on the wall for making me laugh
this morning fans of MMA and the UFC got
some good news this week where there
were reports that Conor McGregor would
be joining Game of Thrones there was a
couple different sources and one of them
happened to be the president of the UFC
Dana White who told TMZ that he thought
it was a good idea and he's glad he's
doing it watch this on the wall have a
source that told them that McGregor will
be playing a pirate on euron greyjoy
screw for his ship the silence this is
actually good news in my opinion because
if the silence is the same on the show
as it is in the books then it screwed
entirely by mutes they're mutes because
of course you're on graduate cut all
their tongues out so if that's the case
that'll be good because we want to worry
about his acting chops we can just watch
him take a nice little supporting role
apparently this came because either Dan
or Dave I don't think I've read anywhere
where it says which one but one of them
is a huge fan of the UFC so they wanted
to have him involved and I guess by all
accounts he's a interesting looking
character so why not sim Jones who
played Loras Tyrell did an interview
with vulture which at first they only
read the blurb of and then I went and
read the whole thing and it's definitely
recommended reading I would look it up a
fire you guys I found out something I
didn't know Loras actually or at least
you know the actor who plays Loras he's
one of the few cast members who's
actually read the Song of Ice and Fire
novels so he has a lot of opinions which
are interesting and you know one of the
highlights here is that he talks about
lorises idea to confess in the show and
you know he talks about how some fans
were saying that it was a weak decision
and you know that's because we really
didn't see what happens down there like
if you have read the books you know that
down in the
dungeons is not a place you want to be
and you know this is the kind of thing
that's been working for powerful bodies
and you know in charge for a long time
people have historically admitted
anything to stop torture it's definitely
not a method that's good about getting
reliable information off of anyone but
if you want them to say that they did
something they didn't do
long term torture pretty much works so
he did you know he did talk about that
how his abuse would have been so
horrendous that he would have basically
said anything when he was brought in
front of the trial and then he talked
about how he thought the series should
end I'll paraphrase his quote which says
that what he thinks needs to happen is
ice and fire are going to go to war a
huge war between those two factions and
through that they're basically going to
destroy themselves this is not just
going to be chaos but destruction and
nothing's really going to be left at the
end of winter so you know basically the
the Iron Throne will be dissolved both
literally and figuratively
physically and ideologically and
basically everything will go back to
individual kingdoms and maybe be some
overseeing board that won't necessarily
take power but will give the power back
to the different people in the different
realms this is a pretty well thought-out
theory that's been around for quite some
time so it's interesting to see that you
know some of these guys do actually get
into the series the actor who played
King Joffrey Baratheon actually has
never even watched the show when he was
interviewed he was like I hear it's
brilliant I probably should watch it but
yeah so you know what I mean they have
busy lives it's not necessarily required
of the job to know what the hell's going
on from there we got some more
interesting photos of set construction
this time in loss of a lettuce where
they're setting up what looks to be
King's Landing scenes you can see the
props it kind of looks like somewhere
similar to where we saw Cersei visit the
sparrow
the high Sparrow last season we'll
probably have more from this location
coming up in the next week so make sure
you check back for spoilers next week on
Friday we got a blast of news that's so
big
well no individual piece of it's so big
but we
got so much information on Friday that's
almost a lot to get through here
first of all Emilia Clarke showed up in
cáceres which we knew she would
eventually but we didn't know where she
was up until this point so at the same
time we got this photo of the VFX team
who works on the dragon scene so that
looks like she'll be out there on the
ambush area shooting the final days
where she you know she gets there with
her dragon or dragons we don't really
know yet we know there's at least one
dragon involved so that's exciting news
then we got Lannister banners hanging in
the plaza de la cebolla tha's that I
showed you in the previous set
construction pictures a few of them are
actually taken close-up by javi Barea
who took some of those other pictures
and you get a little bit of insight into
what might be going on although it's a
little bit confusing because in this
photo on Instagram we can see that it
says Davos is skip now my subscribers
know that Davos was doing a scene near
King's Landing with Tyrion and Gendry no
wait really you haven't seen that one
yet you definitely need to check on the
end screen for my spoiler playlist
because that is a massive one that you
really need to know about but anyway so
Davos was he there is he there he was
there will he be there whenever everyone
else is there in this scene inside the
city we really don't know but yes you
can see there's lots of cool stuff going
on the banners and all these different
props being installed hopefully we'll
get more of this next week I think
they're only shooting there for a couple
days so should be exciting out of
Northern Ireland that same day we got
some interesting photos with some
characters that you may not have
realized have never been anywhere near
each other before in this photo we see
Jorah the hound and torment all who are
likely there to shoot at the wolf hill
quarry scene now we've talked about the
scene we talked about why they're there
in previous spoiler videos so I'm not
going to go all the way through it all
but just think about that for a second
that Jorah spent most of this entire
series traveling around
the East and obviously torment hasn't
gone very far far from the wall and then
the hound I mean the helm is none of
these guys have been together before so
that's pretty exciting
also Jon Snow Kit Harington was seen you
know talking to fans there plus we saw
that shot of him earlier where he's on
that set so these all seem to back up
our earlier ideas about what they're
going to be doing there and it should be
epic so I'm gonna end todays video with
a little bit of Mira or Ellie Kendrick
news she did an interview over at
inverse and if she actually gets into
some Theory stuff which is kind of fun
to read and it's a good article all the
way around but they were talking about
fan theories and this one that I've
always thought it's pretty bad and not
likely to be true but that her and Jon
are actually siblings you know like they
were twins and she just goes into
talking about how they really don't know
what's going on like she's heard the
theory and she thinks it would be cool
for her if it was true but you know when
people ask her about it she's just like
I don't know they don't tell me anything
I have no clue I really wouldn't know
until the day that we were about to see
you know shoot the scene or whatever so
that's kind of fun
and she mentions being involved in the
tourney at Harrenhal History and Laura
narration that she did for the you know
the season 6 DVD set and what I just
want to say if you're watching Ellie it
says here that you want to know more
about Meera and Jojen parentage who the
cranek men are and who your father on
the show Howland is well I do happen to
have two videos that I've made recently
about those subjects so you should check
those out one little thing before I get
into the book giveaway I've been
thinking about starting a new project
because I've been doing a lot of
traveling and it's a brand new channel
that I will probably put out in the next
couple months if you got a second would
you click on this link and subscribe so
I can set the channel up properly you
need like a hundred subscribers and even
though there's no content there there is
some potentially interesting stuff I'm
planning on doing so in the meantime
while you're there
subscribing you can click on the
Instagram link to follow
Instagram account to find out what's
going on I appreciate any help so that's
about it for this week guys I know it's
a long one but hey there's a lot of cool
news so make sure you like the video if
you enjoyed it let's talk about it all
in the comments the book giveaway still
going on so please leave a comment here
on any of my other recent videos when I
reach twenty eight thousand subscribers
I will send one commenter a book in fact
a specific book that is the 20th
anniversary edition of a game of Thrones
by George RR martin all you have to do
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video or any of the others why I
mentioned this giveaway check back
tomorrow for part two of my art of the
Gods reel series if you haven't seen
part one yet go ahead and click on that
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon